vous allez nous jouer un petit quelque
chose ça va être c'est quel qu'est-ce
que vous avez choisi oh une petite
chanson qui s'appelle loulou elle a une
histoire petite promenade dans les r de
Bretagne
dans la petit truc qui mène au bout du
port en face de l'atelier des
dantelières en haut de l'escalier qui
monte à La
Verrière loulou est resté chez elle hier
au soir
encore
la pluie dans la lumière des
Lampades tomb sur les vélos rangés
d'or
adossé au mur le long du magasin de
sport je suis resté assis comme ça au
moins une heure
entière
loulou a changé sa vie et son décor
elle dit qu'elle a trouvé enfin son
nécessaire et ses nouveaux amis valent
mieux que ceux
d'hier on pouvait voir passer le rombre
sur le store
c'était comme une soirée
d'anniversaire on les entend des Rire
jusqu'au
de et puis la pluie est partie doucement
avec le vent du
nord je suis rentré tranquille à pied
sous la nuit claire continu en musique
avec William chellerer c'est la fin de
euh tout de suite après la météo
natthalie riweet le coin roue de Valérie
Maurice et à 20h Béatrice schberg je
vous dis à lundi et on reste avec la
chanson qui te promène partout lesair
abattu ce serait bien que tu comprennes
maintenant qu'il y a plus rien à
faire que tu retrouves en cours un jour
ta raison perdue
loulou ne t'aime plus venez par ici